ينظم اليوسف زين الدين المتحدث من فريق
شاهد يوسف
ما هي مفاجات شاهد للعام الجديد
انطلق المسلسل من ايام ومستمر معنا مسلسل
30 حلقه رح نشوفه تتابعوا من الاحد للخميس
كل اسبوع
الحلو بهذا المسلسل عوده خالتي طبعا دائما
الفنان هدى حسين تبهرنا بادورها اليوم
مصممه الازياء العالميه
امي نسيت حياتها نقدر نحكي نسيت حياتها
الشخصيه حياتها الاسريه ما تزوجت فضلت كل
تركيزها بالشغلها في حدث بخليها انها ترجع
تقابل اختها اللي بتتعرض لازمه صحيه وان
الدير بالها على اولاد اختها فهوان حترجع
تعيش تجربه الامومه شو الصراعات اللي حتى
الي هتخوضها وشل مواقف اللي هتصير بينهم
اولاد اختها يعني هي مش متعوده على هذا
الموضوع ولا الولاد اخت متعودين عليها طيب
بما انه يعني يوسف زين الدين هو الشاهد
على كل ما هو جديد في شهد فمن شديد ايضا
همم ايضا كمان همم بدك غير عوده خالتي في
عنا بعوده خالتي كان همم كمان انا امس ااه
اكلت حاضر الحفل الختامي او تصوير النهائي
وادلنا ناخذ من هدى حسين لقاء سريع هيك
حاول تاخذ منها كليب سريع جاهز هيكون معنا
حسين
والله يعني يمكن يعني كم حلقه من عوده
خالتي مسلسل جديد جوه جديد رؤيه جديده
وجميله واشياء غير متوقعه بالنسبه لي هذا
دور جديد
مشاكل كثيره في مجال المهني وحتى يعني
الصعيد الاسري ايضا لكن همم
الحمد لله انا يعني بفضل رب العالمين
من ابرز الاعمال براندو شرق الموضوع في
اطار كوميدي حدثنا اكثر عنه عبراني
السنه اقدر اسميه انا دراماتي يعني دراما
كوميديا يعني احنا راح نضحك ونتاثر ونبكي
بنفس الوقت فهذا الحلو بهذا المسلسل طبعا
احنا عم نحكي عن عملاقين رح يكونوا
مجموعين مع بعض جون خب جورج خباز وامل
عرفه راح يكون موجودين لاول مره مع بعض
همم نعم بصراحه ديو جميل احنا بنحكي عن
عشر حلقات حلقتين ان شاء الله راح نشوفهم
همم
الرحله بتحبوا نحكي عنها
يعني اعتقد شفته الان كم حلقه عوده خالتي
مسلسل جديد جو جديد رؤيا جديده من المخرج
الاستاذ محمد جمعه
بروديكشن كبير من الاستاذ جمال سنانير
[موسيقى]
ان نتحدث عن نجوم كبار لا كلام بس بدنا
نعرف كواليس التفاصيل
سالتهم شويه عن كيف كواليس العمل وقالوا
لي كانت جدا جميله لدرجه انه حتى كمان زوج
خبازه امل عرفه في بعض المشاهد كان يرتجله
يعني كانت تطلع معهم كلمات والمخرج طبعا
امين
كان يخليهم براحتهم
ويضيف المشاهد لانهم يقدروا يعني تطلع
منهم صادقه
فكانت جدا جميله طبعا احنا بنحكي عن قصه
شغف انه هل كاتب والمخرج الهم جورج خباز
من مسلسل اسمه يوسف
الترقيه الاكشن تاريخيه والله كان في تنوع
كتير كبير يعني ما بقدر اجزم لك بشيء معين
ولكن انا بدي احضر لكم اسبوع الجاي ان شاء
الله قائمه باكثر الاعمال اللي كانت
محظوره على منصه شاهد خلال عام 2022 بس
انا بدايه بدات اقرا فيها واشوفها ما في
شيء
طبعا
بالنسبه للاعمال الدراميه ايضا كمان
موجوده بس كامله من همم رعب همم اه بالضبط
يعني كما تنوع في شاهد وكما التنوع في
صباح العربيه فنقول المشاهد اذا اردتهم ان
ترون الثقافه والسياسه والادب والتاريخ
والجغرافيا والعلوم السينما والسينما
والفن و شاهد كله في صباح العربيه